une cave transformée en clinique ici une
salle d'attente là celle des
consultations dans des conditions
précaires à barkout des médecins
volontaires y traitent les mots
habituels tension artérielle diabète et
autres problèmes médicaux une présence
indispensable pour des civils prises au
piège des violents combats qui font rage
à la surface dans la ville qui comptait
100000 habitants avant la guerre
plusieurs milliers de civils
survivraient encore
à une centaine de kilomètres de là de
l'autre côté du front un hôpital de
Donetsk a été touché selon les autorités
proruses qui contrôlent la ville et sa
région depuis 2014 un bombardement
ukrainien en serait à l'origine
[Musique]
nous avons subi deux frappes ce dimanche
le bâtiment de neurochirurgie juste
derrière nous a été touché ainsi que
celui dédié au diagnostic et au
traitement
un patient aurait perdu la vie et un
autre aurait été blessé